[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend die
Champions League und mehr gibt es gleich
von ganz genau auch von mir einen
schönen guten Abend unsere großen Themen
heute
Äußerungen von Frankreichs Präsidenten
macron sorgen für Ärger braucht Europa
in der China-Politik mehr Distanz zu den
USA
US-Regierung in Alarmstimmung die im
Internet aufgetauchten Geheimdokumente
sein ein sehr ernstes Sicherheitsrisiko
und immer mehr gesprengte Geldautomaten
Bund und Länder fordern von den Banken
mehr Sicherheitsmaßnahmen und drohen
andernfalls mit einem Gesetz
mehr europäische Unabhängigkeit von den
USA im Konflikt zwischen China und
Taiwan fordert Frankreichs Präsidenten
und sorgt damit für Aufregung
schließlich sucht Europa im Konflikt mit
Russland gerade jetzt den engen
Schulterschluss mit den USA über die
Reaktion auf macron sprechen wir gleich
mit unseren Korrespondenten in Brüssel
und Berlin heute hielt macron ein
europapolitische Rede in den
Niederlanden wie er sich da äußerte
berichtete
er könnte jetzt nachlegen oder
zurückrudern Emmanuel macron fuhr
Studenten in den Haar hier war seine
Grundsatzrede mit Spannung erwartet
worden denn zuvor hatte frankreichs
Staatspräsident ein Interview gegeben
der wichtigste satzbezug sich auf Taiwan
und einen drohenden Konflikt zwischen
den USA und China
das Schlimmste wäre es zu denken dass
wir Europäer Mitläufer sein und uns dem
amerikanischen Rhythmus und einer
chinesischen Überreaktion anpassen
das klang nach gleicher Distanz zu den
USA und zu China am Nachmittag Klanges
verhaltener trotz eines großen Wortes
europäische Souveränität ist nicht nur
ein Planspiel oder eine Fantasie in
einer gefährlichen Welt ist sie eine
Notwendigkeit wie gefährlich die Welt
ist zeigte Chinas Regierung über Ostern
Militärübungen vor Taiwans Küste doch
andere Europäer ziehen daraus andere
Schlüsse als macron Tatsache dass er
sich in dem Moment wo Militärübungen vor
der taiwanesischen Grenze stattfinden an
die Seite Chinas stellt und gegen
Amerika stellt entspricht nicht den
europäischen
interessenski betonte die Beziehung zu
den USA sei entscheidend für die
Sicherheit seines Landes und was
konservative Amerikaner über macron
denken spricht ein Senator aus spricht
er für ganz Europa wir helfen gerade in
der Ukraine das ist unser Steuergeld für
Europas Krieg
immer nur hat Europa Impulse gegeben die
Richtung gefällt nicht alle
ja blicken wir genau darauf mit unseren
Komponenten in Berlin und Brüssel zuerst
zu ihnen warum ist der ärgern
ich glaube der Ärger in Brüssel ist so
groß wenn man eigentlich gehofft hatte
in Sachen China mit einer Stimme zu
reden und nun tut man das nicht und gibt
es Streit da war auf der einen Seite
eben die kommissionspräsidentin Ursula
von der Leyen die für Europa einen sehr
kritischen China Kurs formuliert hat und
da ist eben jetzt der französische
Präsident macron der in diesem Interview
doch sehr deutlich gemacht hat dass er
verbal an China ran rückt und eben
Distanz zu den USA sucht und das macht
vor allem den Osteuropäern große Sorgen
weil Amerika ist für Osteuropa quasi die
Schutz macht und die Osteuropäer haben
Angst dass man Worte jetzt Amerika
verprellt und es gibt ja auch die ersten
Reaktion vor allem eben bei den
Republikanern die auf macron sauer sind
und jetzt ein bisschen Anti europäische
Stimmung machen alles sehr kompliziert
wie gesagt die Europäische Union hat
jetzt ein leichtes macron und ein großes
China Problem gehen
man in Berlin
also hier schwanken die Reaktionen
zwischen stumm und schrill aus der SPD
beispielsweise heißt es es sei ein
schwerer Fehler sich als Westen
ausgerechnet im Umgang mit China Spalten
zu lassen die Bundesregierung schweigt
sehr bewusst ist offensichtlich spürbar
um Gelassenheit bemüht und will ganz
offensichtlich dass deutsch-französische
Verhältnis das ja auch schon mal
herzlicher war nicht weiter belasten in
Berlin kennt man einerseits die
neologistischen Töne von macron erneige
ja dazu zuzuspitzen aber genau in diesen
Zuspitzungen werden wenn auch nur hinter
den Kulissen dann problematische
Formulierung benannt das Taiwan als
Problem anderer beschrieben wird der
Sender ein falsches Signal an China als
hielte Europa sich raus und es sende ein
verheerendes Signal in die USA wo ja wie
ihm gehört auch erste Stimmen darauf
hinweisen dann macht doch euren
ukrainekrieg alleine für die anstehende
peking-reise der deutschen
Außenministerin heißt das in jedem Fall
China Diplomatie unter dem Mikroskop
danke für diese Einschätzung
top secret streng geheim heißt es auf
einer Reihe der US-Geheimdienst
Dokumente die vor kurzem im Internet
aufgetaucht sind in ihnen geht es unter
anderem um den Krieg in der Ukraine aber
sind die Dokumente auch tatsächlich echt
und wenn ja welche Auswirkungen haben
die Veröffentlichungen laut US-Regierung
ist ein sehr ernstes Sicherheitsrisiko
entstanden über die Ermittlungen wegen
des Datenlecks und die politischen
Folgen berichtet Benjamin Daniel
so sehen sie aus die Dokumente über
deren Echtheit und Herkunft sich die
Welt den Kopf zerbricht in den sozialen
Medien werden zahlreiche gefälschte
Versionen für Propaganda Zwecke
verbreitet viele der rund 100 geliebten
Papiere scheinen aber tatsächlich
hochsensible Daten zu enthalten glaubt
die US-Regierung
es gibt keine Entschuldigung dafür dass
solche Dokumente in der Öffentlichkeit
auftauchen
auf keinen Fall öffentlich sondern
streng geheim gehalten sein
vieles rund um die leaks ist nach wie
vor unklar was wir bisher wissen die
Dokumente bieten einen Einblick in die
lagebewertung des Krieges Anfang März
sie enthalten taktische Informationen
über die ukrainische Luftabwehr und die
internationalen Bemühungen die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte zu
unterstützen außerdem Hinweise auf
bisher unbekannte Möglichkeiten
russische militärkommunikation abzuhören
satellitenspionage wie das sogenannte
lapis-programm das wohl best gehütete
Geheimnis der US-
unter Berufung auf die Dokumente
berichten sowohl den New York Times als
auch die Washington Post das US-Militärs
an der Schlagkraft der geplanten
Frühjahrsoffensive der Ukraine zweifeln
in Kiew hingegen will man davon nichts
wissen und spielt die Veröffentlichungen
herunter derweil raten Militärexperten
zur Vorsicht bei der Bewertung
in diesem Fall analysieren viele leihen
die Inhalte und sagen Dinge darüber die
einfach nicht wahr sind
nichtsdestotrotz verringert das
natürlich nicht die Sorge darüber
welchen Schaden solche
Veröffentlichungen anrichten können
die Suche nach dem Leck geht weiter wie
groß der Schaden am Ende tatsächlich ist
auch im Hinblick auf das
Vertrauensverhältnis zu den US
Verbündeten ist im Moment noch schwer
abzusehen
und über die Pentagon liegt gleich ein
heute live mit Militärexperte Gustav
gressel und
washingtonspondendissen um 19:30 Uhr in
der ZDF heute App und unseren Social
Media Kanälen
bei den bevorstehenden Wahlen in der
Türkei dürfte es für Präsident Erdogan
so knapp werden wie seit vielen Jahren
nicht Erdogan steht unter Druck auch
wegen seines Krisenmanagements im Zuge
der Erdbebenkatastrophe heute hat seine
islamisch konservative Regierungspartei
AKP offiziell den Wahlkampf eingeläutet
Erdogan sprach Gehaltserhöhung für
Beamte und Rentner und Steuersenkungen
die Parlaments und Präsidentenwahlen
sind gleichzeitig am 14 Mai
und in Umfragen liegt Erdogan hinter dem
gemeinsamen Kandidaten der Opposition
Jörg Brase in Istanbul wie versucht
Erdogan Boden weg zu machen
und vor allem durch teure
Wahlversprechen so Willi wir haben es
gehört Renten und Löhne jährlich über
das Inflationsniveau anheben die
Inflation liegt im Moment bei über 50
Prozent die will er wieder in den
einstelligen Bereich absenken er
verspricht neue mega Verkehrsprojekte er
will die Jugend gewinnen indem er zum
Beispiel Schüler in einem Computer und
ein Handy spendiert vor allem aber will
er natürlich dass Erdbebengebiet sehr
schnell wieder aufbauen wie er das
bezahlen will das Verräter heute nicht
der Auftritt heute wird beim Wahlvolk
eher wenig Enthusiasmus hervorgerufen
haben die Veranstaltung vor den eigenen
Anhängern den Ankara die war auch
seltsam verhalten das mag damit
zusammenhängen dass sie mitten in den
Fasten Monat Ramadan viel und viele
waren doch sichtlich müde in zwei Wochen
erst beginnt dann die heiße
Wahlkampfphase und da wird Präsident
Erdogan sicher innerlicher auftreten
müssen als er das heute getan hat
danke schön Istanbul
die deutsche Wirtschaft könnte dieses
Jahr leicht in die Rezession rutschen so
jedenfalls die Prognose des
Internationalen Währungsfonds der einen
Rückgang um 0,1% erwartet optimistischer
waren zuletzt führende deutsche
Wirtschaftsinstitute die für 2023 ein
kleines Plus Vorhersagen beim Ausblick
auf die Weltwirtschaft dämpft der IWF
ebenfalls die Erwartungen wegen
steigender Zinsen werde sich das globale
Wachstum verlangsamen und nur noch 2,8%
betragen
bei vielen bei der Schock groß als die
radikalislamischen Taliban im August
2021 in Kabul die machtübernahmen die
Bundesregierung setzte mehrere Programme
auf mit denen vor allem Afghanen und
Afghanen in Deutschland Schutz finden
sollten die durch die Herrschaft der
Taliban besonders stark gefährdet sind
aber auch wer bereits eine
Aufnahmezusage bekommen hat darf derzeit
nicht nach Deutschland kommen warum
berichten Julia Held und Armin Körper
eine kleine Wohnung im Zentrum von
Tehran eine junge afghanische
Frauenrechtlerin und ihre Familie die
Koffer stehen bereit in ein paar Tagen
sollte ein Flieger sie alle nach
Deutschland bringen doch dann vergangene
Woche plötzlich eine E-Mail Deutschland
habe die Aufnahme aus Afghanistan
vorübergehend ausgesetzt die junge Frau
die nicht erkannt werden will zeigt uns
die Pässe samt gültiger Visa ausgestellt
von der deutschen Botschaft in Teheran
unter Lebensgefahr war die Familie dafür
nach Iran gereist weil es in Afghanistan
keine funktionierende Botschaft mehr
gibt
unsere große Sorge ist jetzt dass unser
iranisches Visum ausläuft und unser
deutsches Visum auch ausläuft und wir
nach Afghanistan zurück müssen eine
afghanische Frauenrechtlerin und ihre
Familie die trotz Aufnahme Zusage und
gültiger Visa nicht nach Deutschland
einreisen dürfen wir fragen nach im
Auswärtigen Amt Hintergrund für den
Aufnahmestopp seien vereinzelte Hinweise
auf mögliche missbrauchsversuche bis zur
Etablierung neuer sicherheitsmechanis
könnten erst einmal keine Einreise nach
Deutschland von aufgenommenen
afghanischen Staatsangehörigen
stattfinden wie lange das dauert und was
das für diejenigen bedeutet deren Visa
ablaufen erklärt uns keiner ein
Verfahren an dem der asyl- und
migrationsexperte Matthias Lehner
Zweifel hat wenn die Bundesregierung
sich nicht an so ein Verfahren hält
sondern einfach aus
allgemeingültigen Gründen das Visum
zurückzieht dann begeht sie tatsächlich
einen Rechtsbruch kritik kommt auch von
der migrationexpertin der CDU seraphyla
wir reden über Frauen die dem Taliban
regime entkommen sind und der Vorwurf
den man hier eher machen muss ist wieso
man das nicht voneinander trennen kann
dass Frauen mit Kindern der Zugang
tatsächlich jetzt gewährleistet wird und
so wartet nicht nur diese Familie in
Teheran dringend auf Antworten aus
Deutschland und dass das Land das
Versprechen dass es gegeben hat auch
einlöst
und ein ausführlichen Bericht über die
ausgesetzten Visa für Menschen aus
Afghanistan sehen Sie um 21 Uhr in
unserem investigativ Magazin frontal
und wir schauen nach mehrmal seitdem
sich dort das Militär an die Macht
geputzt hat gibt es immer wieder
Anschläge auf die Opposition heute
erreichen uns Meldungen vom wohl
blutigsten angriffsleiter macht
Übernahme offenbar wurde in einer Region
der es besonders heftigen Widerstand
gegen die Militärs gibt eine
Veranstaltung war bei dir von bis zu 100
Toten ist bislang die Rede
erneut sind im Iran Mädchen an Schulen
vergiftet worden seit mehr als vier
Monaten werden solche Angriffe verübt
wer dahinter steckt immer noch unklar
nicht nur Angehörige der betroffenen
Mädchen werfen den Behörden Versagen bei
der Aufklärung vor die Einzelheiten von
Jörg Brase
Schülerinnen Ringen vor ihrem
Schulgebäude in der Provinz ist verhan
um Luft es sind Bilder von heute die
Anschläge mit Reizgas auf Schulen gehen
weiter die genauen Umstände sind
ungeklärt die Behörden scheinen machtlos
viele aber glauben dass die Führung die
Anschläge gar nicht aufklären will
ich glaube sie wollen den Mädchen Angst
einjagen wegen der letzten Proteste sie
haben herausgefunden wer mitgemacht hat
und wollen sie nun bestrafen
anders so mein Beobachter sei kaum zu
erklären warum diese Anschläge im
Überwachungsstaat Iran nicht verhindert
werden können
die Angreifer mit dem inneren Zirkel der
Macht verbunden sein beantwortet sich
die Frage warum die Täter nicht
ermittelt und ernsthaft verfolgt werden
von selbst
sehr viel konsequenter wie Irans Führung
dagegen Frauen aufspüren die das
Kopftuch nicht oder nicht
vorschriftsgemäß tragen dafür soll
verstärkt Kameraüberwachung auf den
Straßen eingesetzt werden
moderne Technologie einsetzen um die
Personen zu identifizieren die Frauen
bekommen eine Verwarnung im
Wiederholungsfall werden Ihre Dokumente
den Justizbehörden übergeben
bereits jetzt wird Frauen in Teheran die
gegen die Kopftuch Regeln verstoßen der
Zutritt zur öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln
Banken und vielen Geschäften verweigert
ja wir müssen uns an die Job abgesetzte
halten wenn wir keinen Ärger haben und
Konsequenzen vermeiden wollen aber etwas
dass die aufgezwungen wird ist niemals
angenehm wenn sie Kameras wegen des
Kopftuchs installieren warum dann nicht
wegen der Anschläge nichts ist wichtiger
als ein Menschenleben
die Aufklärung der giftgasanschläge auf
Schulen aber lässt auch nach über 4
Monaten weiter auf sich warten
statistisch gesehen passiert es mehr als
einmal pro Nacht irgendwo in Deutschland
kriminelle sprengen einen der rund
55.000 Geldautomaten in die Luft weil
die Fallzahlen massiv steigen fordern
die Innenministerin und Minister der
Länder von den Banken nun mehr
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen notfalls per Gesetz
2022 wurden bundesweit 496 Geldautomaten
gesprengt 7 und 27% mehr als im Jahr
zuvor die Täter kommen vor allem aus den
Niederlanden entsprechend sind vor allem
Bundesländer im Westen betroffen auch
wenn das Phänomen ein bundesweites ist
Thomas münden berichtet
die Täter suchen sich meist kleinere
Filialen aus um Geldautomaten zu
springen schützen könnten sich die
Banken mit Farbpatronen oder
spezialklebern die die Geldscheine bei
einem Einbruch sofort zu einem nicht
lösbaren Block verschweißen in den
Niederlanden z.B ist das lange Standard
in Deutschland zögern viele Banken wegen
der Kosten entstandene Schäden sind
versichert doch die Innenminister von
Bund und Ländern fordern jetzt mehr
Engagement in der Vorbeugung eine
Maßnahme allein wird's nicht richten
sondern wie immer in der
Kriminalitätsbekämpfung müssen mehrere
Maßnahmen zusammenkommen und dazu gehört
auch die Technik viele Banken aber bauen
die Automaten ab statt sie sicherer zu
machen die Banken sehen das
unterschiedlich Personal wird abgebaut
Öffnungszeiten wird jetzt kommen wir
noch die Automaten weg
nicht gut ich hole mein Geld inzwischen
sowieso an der Supermarktkasse weil es
einfach viel praktischer ist mehr
Sicherheit nur auf eigene Kosten lehnt
die Kreditwirtschaft klar ab kein
Interview schriftlich heißt es Zitat es
ist schwer nachzuvollziehen dass die
alleinige Verantwortung für die
Verhinderung von Sprengungen bei Banken
und Sparkassen liegen soll die Sicherung
der Bargeld Infrastruktur gelingt nur im
Schulterschluss mit Politik und
Strafverfolgungsbehörden
doch finanzielle Unterstützung der
Behörden zum Schutz von Automaten
schließt der Minister aus davon halte
ich nun gar nichts für die Sicherheit
muss immer jeder selber sorgen
es geht nicht ums Geld sondern auch um
den Schutz von Anwohnern und Passanten
die durch immer stärkere Sprengstoffe in
Gefahr gerieten wenn die Banken nicht
freiwillig nachbessern so die
Innenminister unisono wäre das als
letztes Mittel eine gesetzliche Regelung
geben die die Banken zu besserem Schutz
verpflichtet
im Osten Russlands auf der Halbinsel kam
chat-ka ist da Vulkan civilch
ausgebrochen und hat eine riesige
Aschewolke verursacht die örtlichen
Behörden gaben eine Warnung für den
Luftverkehr heraus die Wolke soll eine
Höhe bis zu 20 km erreicht haben es
könne jederzeit zu Asche Explosionen
kommen auf dem Boden hat sich eine dicke
Ascheschicht gebildet der lutsch gilt
als einer der aktivsten Vulkane
Russlands
sie war eine urkellnerin ihre Schlager
wurden zu Karneval Hits und als
Schauspielerin war sie ein halbes
Jahrhundert im Geschäft nun ist Lotti
Krieg im Alter von 81 Jahren gestorben
ihre Karriere begann auf der Bühne Willy
Millowitsch holte sie an sein Theater
auch später im Fernsehen kreuzten sich
ihre Wege dort die Kriege spielte in
zahlreichen Filmen und Serien mit auch
in einer Soko Köln Folge im ZDF
verheiratet war sie mit dem Schauspieler
ernst hilbich
und jetzt kommen wir zur Champions
League Sven es klingt ja wie ein Finale
ist es aber noch nicht oder nein es ist
noch nicht denn es ist erst das
Viertelfinale Hinspiel zwischen
Manchester City und Bayern München aber
in der Tat treffen hier heute zwei Titel
Favoriten aufeinander und es ist auch
ein Duell der Top-Trainer
gewohnt fokussiert Thomas Tuchel vor
seinem ersten Champions League Spiel als
Bayern Trainer gegen eine der derzeit
besten Mannschaften der Welt Manchester
City vor allem wegen Erlinger Holland
der Ex BVB Torjäger in top Formel hat in
seinem verteidigungsplan kein Experiment
wie das einer niederländischen Spieler
und Trainer Legende vorgesehen ich meine
das Vergnügen gehabt mit Johann Kreuz zu
sprechen der mir von dem Stürmer dann
berichtet hat
den sie nie in den Griff bekamen mit
Barcelona bis er irgendwann gesagt hat
wir decken ihn jetzt nicht mehr und dann
hat er aufgehört heute gegen sie zu
schießen das werden wir morgen nicht
ausprobieren
Orlando Sturm von dort bei den Bayern
super-moting fällt ver letzt aus das
letzte koduell zwischen tokel und City
Trainer Guardiola entschied der deutsche
für sich das Champions League Finale
2021 mit Chelsea es wäre gegen Julian
nagelsmann schwierig gewesen es wird
auch schwierig gegen Totten ein
Viertelfinale Duell bei dem sich beide
Teams mächtig strecken müssen
Alexander Zverev hat die zweite Runde
des ATP Masters von Monte Carlo erreicht
der deutsche Tennisprofi besiegte den
Kasachen Alexander bublik in drei Sätzen
zwischenzeitlich wurden Erinnerungen an
seine schwere Verletzung wach
Schrecksekunde in Monte Carlo anders als
bei den French Open 2022 wo Zverev sich
am Fuß verletzte Monate pausieren musste
geht es weiter bei seinem ersten Turnier
seither auf Sand tut sich der 25-Jährige
schwer verliert den ersten Satz mit
schwachen Aufschlägen 3 zu 6
Verbesserungen zweiten wo er dreiviertel
der ersten Aufschläge ins Feld bringt
schließlich Sex zu zwei gewinnt
ausgeglichen Satz 3 du blickst Aussetzer
ibbenden verhefte den Weg zum Sex zu 4
und damit zum ersten Sieg in der dritten
Begegnung mit dem Kasachen nächster
Gegner der Spanier Roberto Bautista gut
und das war's vom Sport Jana
morgen regnet es wieder mehr dazu gleich
beim Wetter von Essence um 21:45 Uhr
läuft das heute journal moderiert von
Dunja Hayali tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter neuer Regen zieht
auf von Westen her und das hängt mit
diesem Tiefe zusammen das Fronten System
erreicht uns in der zweiten Nachthälfte
vorher gibt es noch ein bisschen Regen
im Osten der zieht ab und dann ist es
sogar zwischendurch mal trocken schauen
wir uns das mal im Detail an im Osten
also allmählich trockenes Wetter nach
Nordosten noch einige Schauer die
abziehen aber aus westlichen Richtung
kommt kompakte Wolken auf und da ist
schon Regen mit im Gepäck Temperaturen
gehen zurück auf -1 Grad im Osten
Deutschlands milder entlang des Rheins
mit sechs bis neun Grad bis im Südwesten
Deutschlands morgen werden am Vormittag
zwischen Oder und Neiße noch Trockeneis
mit sonnigen Abschnitt aber dann zieht
sie auch zu so wie in den anderen
Gebieten und im Westen zum Nachmittag
sogar Schauer und Gewitter mit dabei bei
Temperaturen von 9 Grad z.B in
Schleswig-Holstein und Grad nach Süden
hier ist es am wärmsten die nächsten
Tage sind weiterhin unbeständig am
Donnerstag am 11 noch im Osten trocken
und an den Alpen bis auf 1000 Meter
Schneefall 5 bis 13 Grad und am Freitag
wärmer aber auch wieder unbeständiger
ein schöner Abend